[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Peters Morgan I'm censored tonight
the Home Secretary says we've forgotten
how to work labor says bosses should be
banned from calling or texting staff
outside of office hours it's with
Britain work shy we'll debate that with
union bosses ordering ministers to stop
calling his workers lazy snowflakes but
what if they are lazy snowflakes
president zielinski makes a short visit
to London and says Ukraine needs Jets is
it time to give Ukraine whatever it
needs to end Putin's War we'll debate
that plus prisons banned from saying
convict to prisoners presumably because
it hurts their feelings a biological man
enters a female University boat race and
kids are being taught that women have
penises no this isn't an episode of some
bizarre spoof this is actually happening
well professor gadsad says that common
sense is dead and he knows who killed it
he'll discuss all those stories with me
live
foreign
[Music]
like to think of ourselves as a
hard-working nation of ambitious
industrious grafters rain or shine
usually the former of course we pull
ourselves up by the bootstraps and we
get the job done but lately this has
been gone for a few years an infectious
disease has rippled through our
Workforce not covid I would call it work
shy wasteral disease and apparently
highly contagious firstly would be
walloped by endless strikes and War
cards all year and the other workers
were still working hundreds of thousands
of people who gave up during covert and
never went back many more are still
glued to their kitchen tables working
from home well three years I'm from the
pandemic a whopping 44 of workers still
spend at least part of the week at home
half of the Civil Service the Machinery
of the government itself no longer
bothers going to the office and some
government Department 71 percent of
staff are running the country from their
sofas more concerned with the capacity
of their fridge than the bus and Dave
Penman the union boss charged with
whipping them into shape responded by
well whining about being called names
now having been told that you're lazy
woke and efficient remainer activist
snowflake you're also now apparently a
Machiavellian genius able to unseat
ministers and undermine the settled well
of government
will be you conference
had enough of us
at some point
at some point we have to say enough is
enough
would have been a full audience if
they'd all come into work well today the
Homer secretary swella bravaman in her
latest attention-seeking broadside said
the Brits are forgetting how to work for
ourselves and we need homegrown fruit
Pickers and Lorry drivers to control
immigration and to my astonishment I
found myself nodding with Miss Bravo for
the first time possibly ever on this she
may well have a good point well now
Labor's secure starmer who might also be
the next prime minister says he'll
enshrine in law the right to work from
home and ban bosses I love this bit from
sending emails and texts outside of
working hours
I keep reading the jobs are under threat
from The Galloping rise of artificial
intelligence amongst many other things
but also read that the fastest growing
type of small business in the U.S is
content creator and the 50 million
people worldwide now say their
occupation is influencing well that
means they photograph that avocados for
a living and pay the bills by not paying
the bills and living with their parents
until they're 45. well the good news is
there is a cure for work shy waste or
disease and Dr Morgan's prescription is
this but down to baguettes we discover
the Lost daughter wearing trousers
get your lazy sniveling bag size back to
work well on that tender inclusive note
I'm joined by the General Secretary of
the FDA Union Dave Penman the
businessman and founder of Pimlico
plumbers Charlie Mullins and talk to
your vehicle editor Kate McCann in case
you're wondering why the the backdrop is
not our normal glowing colorful graphic
screens we've got what's called a
technical hitch in the business so
there's a kind of funeral it looks so
bad it almost looks like GB news I can
only apologize to my to my uh to my
viewers for this temporary hitch which
hopefully we will resolve but it sort of
adds the right kind of somberness I
think to this debate so all right Dave
Ben
here's my problem with what you said
what if one of your workers just happens
to be a lazy woke inefficient remainer
snowflake
well it's not been my experience of that
but what if they are serious questions
well then like any business or any
industry you would deal with people who
are not performing well we have no
problem with that um in dealing with
performance the problem is ministers are
using this as an issue just sticking a
bash to Civil Service they're not basing
it on any facts around whether people
who work in hybrid environments which
sometimes at home and sometimes at work
um are any less productive or more
productive they're just doing it to kind
of Trot out an attack well they have so
many civil servants just suck up it's
not just civil servants it's it's I know
that but why are so many of your workers
working from home so because I mean some
people were doing it before the pandemic
the pandemic I think in many Industries
accelerated that move if you look before
the pandemic actually about 70 of the
private sector we're working at some
point at home that's now but this can't
be right for a country trying to compete
on the global stage with China or
America and it's in India I mean if our
work ethic is basically get up go to
your sofa so watch a bit of daytime
Telly which is actually quite riveting
at the moment if it's that and then you
do a bit of work and you con your bosses
you're doing a full shift I mean if it
was that you'd be right but it's not
that and also how do you know what
they're doing because they're producing
if not the same then more they're
working more hours because they're not
commuting anymore it works for them it
works for employers why would the
private sector why would private sector
organizations when it's the bottom line
okay that's one of the biggest sectors
where this is working as a finance
sector now you're telling me those big
Banks and international finances houses
don't care about the bottom Lane all
right yeah their workers in many cases
in bigger proportions working okay I'm
going to come to Charlie about the work
part of this in a moment but just on the
on the bullying aspect the dominant Rob
which blew up this whole idea of how
people should be treated in the
workplace when I went through all the
stuff on Rob I've got no trouble Rob I
think he was pretty homeless in many
many ways but when I looked for the
Smoking Gun of what he was supposed to
have done to these all civil servers I
didn't really find one was I missing
something I mean it's raising your voice
in the workplace now banned is holding
people that work for you to you know
quite firm account and being heavily
critical of what you think is shoddy
work are any of those things tolerated
anymore or is that all love limits of
course yeah but that's not with the
report phone the port report found out
what was he doing that he abuse these
parties humiliated what does that mean
though what was he doing because Harry
treated them how we talked give me an
example treat me like he was treating
somebody well you know what the report
didn't give those kind of level of
details but nobody knows that's because
they then won't identify people that
came up with conclusions this was an
independent but do you know do you know
though
do you know what he was doing I I
witnessed so give me a bit of the Rob
treatment so I'm serious well I wouldn't
want to humiliate you I wouldn't want it
you wouldn't humiliate me I wouldn't
want I wouldn't want short of mentioning
my football team's performance yesterday
you cannot humiliate me yeah but have me
only in someone at what which is what he
was found to have done
um targeting individuals which is what
he was going to have done remember this
was an independent Casey who had
investigated this wasn't some walk uh HR
investigation we don't know because we
weren't told what was going on Charlie
there are two issues here one is how
people get treated in the workplace but
the bigger one I think for you with your
view on this is this thing about work
from home it seems to me the Brits are
rushing to either abandon work or work
from home or in massive numbers go on to
state benefits and just avoid doing any
work at all you put all this together
and the impression that we're giving to
other countries is that basically we've
become work shy and that's exactly true
exactly true what you said Dave about 70
of the private sector working from home
then figure is not right mate private
seventy percent what do you say then I
said 22 percent of the private sector
but in some sectors during covert it was
up to 70 yeah well I mean that's that's
rubbish in here but the the private
sector have to go to work they've got no
choice but obviously the public sector
they're being paid by us the taxpayer
are we happy with what what is it 300
000 civil seven uh not from thirty
thousand civil servants working from 60
000 civil sermons over 30 000 working
from home taxpayers paying for it it's
not working it's two years after covid
and they're still at home there's no
reason no excuse whatsoever all the
offices are half empty they're paying
for lighting they're paying for security
it's just not working I mean they're
taking a piss so the biggest sector
where homeworking is prevalent is the
finance sector
and much greater numbers than it is in
the public sector so if that was the
case if this doesn't work if people who
are only in it to make money found that
people were book shy and they were at
the fridge all the time why would they
continue to do it they save money
because the reduced their office costs
the staff like it because they get great
flexibility
and and they still make money so okay
no no hang on let me just say let me
bring the the very patient lady waiting
at the end of the day it takes one hour
for the for the civil servants to answer
a phone how can it be work all right let
me bring in case so okay I mean one of
the things that made me laugh most was
this Kia St armor initiative that moving
to a place where no boss can contact
their staff after a certain time of the
evening I mean I I've spent my entire
career being bothered at all times of
day and night my bosses and I I just
wouldn't cross my mind to complain about
that if you don't like being bothered do
a job which doesn't require you to be
bothered yeah and it's difficult to see
how that would work in politics for
example when most operations are
expected to be on their brief 24 hours a
day or whenever they are awake I put
this to the labor party at the weekend
actually and they did admit that he
would probably end up being a code of
conduct it would probably only apply to
certain types of jobs it will not apply
across the board because it's not
feasible but this whole conversation is
a fascinating one what Labor's trying to
get at is this idea that social media
that artificial intelligence is changing
the way that we work and we need to
protect people from those changes but
everything has a knock-on effect if you
don't go into work for example the
number of dry cleaners near offices the
number of sandwich shops new offices the
number of coffee bars go out of business
those people jobs those people's jobs
are impacted there is a knock-on effect
yes all exactly the options and changes
newspaper sales are down in all the
areas where work from home has just
carried on because people aren't coming
in and spending the kind of money they
would on newspapers Provisions sandwich
bars all that kind of spending in a
different way they're spending on online
deliveries which means that parcel
companies therefore are needed far more
but it also means that Royal Mail can't
cope and we need to change the way that
Royal Mail is working it's a it's a huge
societal change and I think there are
some valid points to all of these
arguments but everything will have an
impact on lots of other things says you
know I just think more British people
should be taking the jobs that we're
currently farming out literally to
foreign workers I think she's got a
point isn't she well this is this they
hear what she said
we need to get overall immigration
numbers down
and we mustn't forget how to do things
for ourselves
there is no good reason why we can't
train up enough truck drivers butchers
fruit Pickers Builders or welders
you see I think that is an election
boosting
attitude to work I think a lot of people
will think she's got a point they're
also going to think we have all this
obsessive interest in the small boats
part of immigration debate and this
legitimate we shouldn't have this number
of illegal people coming in in the way
they are but net migration may get over
a million I was reading at the weekend a
million people coming in now that shows
that this country has a great heart to
people from Ukraine Afghanistan Syria
wherever it may be but it's not
sustainable is it okay I mean is that is
that sustainable politically for the
conservative party you've promised to
get these numbers down to have a million
figure but this is sustainable for the
country well clearly it's not
sustainable for the conservative party
you've seen a succession of very senior
conservatives standing on a stage today
essentially telling their prime minister
that it's not working for them which is
something you generally see when a
government loses an election not in the
18 months before they try and win one
which tells you a lot about the state of
politics I think if you try and unpack
though what Sue Ella Bravo is saying
about work it gets very interesting the
unemployment rate in this country is
incredibly low honestly but the number
of people on on benefits is now millions
and millions and millions of those
people have been out of work for a very
long time it's a very difficult problem
to solve because those people may be
disabled they may have mental health
problems have we become an easy touch
for people gaming the system this but
but take it further okay you're right
there are lots of people on long-term
unemployment very hard problem to solve
takes a lot of money takes a lot of time
isn't quick look at the number of people
who are coming in yes net migration may
may hit a million but lots of those have
come from Hong Kong they've come from
places like Ukraine they're people that
we've welcomed in but they're also
people who've been on shortage
occupation lists because we don't have
enough people trained in certain types
of work to be able to work in this
country earlier on today I was speaking
to a fruit farmer in Angus he needs 4
000 people to be able to to get his
strawberry crops onto the market every
single six months there are only 4 000
people unemployed in his particular area
and most of them are not capable of
doing those jobs which is why in his
view he has to get people from abroad to
do them there is I mean don't lie let me
bring Dave back in on this just some
Workforce perspective I remember talking
to a chief executive of the supermarket
chain every Christmas without fail
rather than have local Pickers pick the
Brussels sprouts for Christmas they used
to fly in from Eastern Europe
several thousand workers to these places
I think in East Anglia where they picked
all the Brussels sprouts and that's how
they did it it was cheaper to do that
that is ridiculous well I think it
depends how you want to run your economy
do you you know if you look at what are
successful economies you know we we
often talk about the Australian
immigration system as they kind of
bespoke one the points-based system you
know that's full of immigrants coming in
and doing seasonal work coming in for a
few years and walking bringing on
specific occupations and that walks and
drives it can this country sustain a net
migration of a million people well I
think that it's a system that this
government has designed my question my
question was can the country sustain
that I I think probably if you would say
if that was a yearly figure that's not
going to be the case but what we're
probably trying to do just now rebalance
assess them we have huge shortages in
places like the NHS and social care a
lot of these people I mean every
restaurant I talk to they can't get
started you know you know the Home
Secretary was talking about about those
issues and kind of lecturing business
around that if Government paid more in
areas like NHS and social care perhaps
more British workers we can't pay
everybody what they want or the country
goes bankrupt and these strikes aren't
helping I mean they're going on and on
and on in all sectors and that is also
contributing to this General sense of
the country creaking up the seams well
again stuff that the government can
solve the Consol it can by giving them
all what they're asking for but there's
also increasingly it seems to me an
unreasonable attitude from some of the
Unions would you accept that no I
wouldn't accept of course you would none
of you ever do it none of you ever do
but even if I sat here as a union you
know where I want 50 of my workers he's
got a point right he's got a point can
you be thinking I should think I'm 50.
right but if you if you're if you're a
government and you want the NHS to run
you're competing and saying don't want
people to work in this NHS or they want
skilled people to go and walk elsewhere
that road you've got to pay the going
rate Charlie yeah I'm going to say we've
become work sure I've become very lazy
and the benefit system is undoubtedly
ruined a lot of people from going to
work and they're working from home and
all that type of thing we've just become
Workshop we yourself great work ethics
and I think we need to with the
exception by the way of my three
panelists tonight you've come in here at
8 15 at night to put a shift in that's
called a shifting can't do it before I
let you go okay we're gonna have a
debate about uh Ukraine in a moment just
how significant was this today with
zelenski coming to see which is soon
like and what sunak is saying about what
he wants to do with Ukraine it's hugely
significant I the Ukrainian presence of
landscape recognizes that Rishi Cena
offering to spearhead this you know
coalition to try and get jets is going
to be the important part of the next
stage of what he needs the question now
is Will those countries that can offer
f-16s which is not this country because
we don't have them will they put their
money where their mouths are and will
they offer those jobs you know when I
went to see zelenski in in Ukraine last
summer he was when the leadership race
was going on here and he obviously was
like Boris Johnson very much was already
given him and he he said to me what's
Richie sunne going to do with us is he
going to be as supportive he's really he
was desperate because he relies on the
support from the British leading the way
in Europe which is ironic even we've
just split from the European Union but
he felt we were leading the way it can
be very interesting to see how this all
plays out thank you it's my pack
apologies for the Grim background you
look like the sort of Supreme Court of
the United States which well we could
probably do a lot worse than you thought
uh good to see you all thank you very
much Ron says the next president zoleski
as I said made a surprise is the UK
today and says he needs Jets is it time
to give Ukraine whatever it needs to end
Putin's barbaric war debate that next
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored debating
the breaking news and talking to the
biggest names Piers Morgan is live every
week with a host of stars uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
well the Kremlin issued a chilling
morning of retaliatory actions today
after prime minister Rishi sune plays
more support for Ukraine president
zelenski made a short visit to the UK as
he attempts to secure more military
support for Ukraine in his fight against
Russia after a two-hour meeting in
checkers which he soon act announced
he'll send hundreds of long-range
missiles and armed drones but zielinski
wants fighter jets and the UK won't at
the moment commit to that
today we spoke about the Jets very
important topic for us because we can't
control the sky we want to create these
Jets Coalition we are going to be a key
part of the Coalition of countries that
provides that support to Vladimir and
Ukraine now it is not a straightforward
thing as vladder and I have been
discussing to make build up that fighter
combat aircraft capability it's not just
the provision of planes it's also the
training of pilots and all the logistics
that go alongside that
well the UK has gone further than any
other European country providing weapons
but is it enough to help Ukraine defeat
Putin once and for all in a moment I
would get an expert view from the former
head of the British army Lord Dana the
first time joined by the man on Sunday
columnist Peter Hitchens Peter welcome
to Piers Morgan uncensored
pleasure to be here so look what is your
view of the Ukraine war
how do you think this now ends what
should the UK be doing
well I think it's all civilization
sensible people should be making every
receivable effort to bring it to an end
a huge numbers of happy innocent persons
have been turned into corpses and
refugees cities have been blasted into
pieces uh houses turned to ruins and
economy is smashed and the the whole of
Ukraine now faces continuing destruction
I do not see what interest serves the
world to continue with this with the
absolutely interested in the Ukrainian
people for there to be peace talks which
would bring this awfulness to an end
how would the peace talks go I mean are
you suggesting that Ukraine are you
suggesting Ukraine should give up
territory that has been illegally seized
by Russia
if I was saying that I would say that
I'm sorry I'm asking the question I know
and I'm saying I'm not saying that so
there you are that's that's that one's
sold good doing any any other questions
I've got a lot of questions yes I mean
what do you think these peace talks
would lead to because
he wants to keep control of the
territory he's taken and probably some
more uh Ukraine is absolutely adamant
they shouldn't be seeding any territory
they even want Crimea back for reasons
which are perfectly obvious if you spend
time with ukrainians so my question for
you is you think you can end with peace
talks how does that end if the
ukrainians won't give up any territory I
won't be there at these talks the people
who will be involved would be the
governments and the two farmers and
countries and they will decide but it
seems to me do you do you must I must
ask you by giving the sound of your
questions do you like War have you seen
War do you know what a human body looks
like after a boy that's passed away okay
well I would say I would I would answer
that I would answer that Peter by saying
is I think you know because actually
your brother uh Christopher wrote for me
at the time I uh and he opposed my
position on this I opposed vociferously
is that it's sort of the mirror of the
war in Iraq uh which was sadly I was
unsuccessful in trying to get that
stopped however my brother was a British
army colonel and served for 37 years in
the Army and he served in places like
Iraq and Afghanistan so yeah I got an
indirect uh feedback on what a war is
like and no nobody likes War you'll
never meet a soldier who says they like
War however as in 1939 when the world
and I say the world not just Ukraine
when the world is confronted with an
evil dictator who thinks he can just
March into neighboring countries and
Destroy them and kill thousands if tens
of thousands of people and then take
their land the world has a duty in my
opinion as it did in 39 to stand up to
that person and that person right now is
Vladimir Putin so that would be my
position but the world has stood up to
him his his uh his offensive was being
bullied his intentions as far as we know
what they were have not been achieved
and they're not likely to be achieved so
now we have a position where the the the
two sides are at something like a cell
mate we don't know I I don't make any
pretense unlike everybody else on the
trail of Journalism to be a military
expert I don't know what the shape of
the Ukrainian offensive which we're told
about something will be or whether it
will succeed but even so it seems to me
that the time has come for us to make an
effort to bring an answer War yeah but
the way you bring it into it shortly it
seems to me we've been very successful
Europe and America in arming the
ukrainians to to resist having their
country taken by Putin and they've been
incredibly successful in doing that and
there's now a real belief amongst
ukrainians and president zielinski that
if they get enough of the military
hardware that they need they can launch
a counter-offensive and actually drive
Russia and the Russian forces out of the
territory that's been seized I don't
think they've got any intention of
waging any kind of Peace anytime soon
because as far as they're concerned
they've had a quarterback country taken
well
you're right there is no pressure on
them from the great pass to make peace
there is no General pressure on them
there's no pressure from Western public
opinion to make peace so you you may
well be right it's it's astonishing to
remember that so vladimirski was
actually elected as president of Ukraine
on a peace ticket was he actually stood
before his people said this there is a
there is a great war going on in my
country which as you probably know
started in 2014 not 2022 it's time it
was over and we must take steps to do so
but that was before Vladimir Putin
invaded I know it was but lots of things
were before but I think it's important
for you to understand this episode has
background and and many many elements in
it which are not much discussed in the
in in the January rather um how should I
say uh
cursory coverage which the causes and
nature rewards is given this country but
zielinsky was a peace candidate he was
frustrated in that by some certain
country who preferred but as you know as
you know the situation dramatically
changed February last year when Putin
invade invaded Ukraine and you gotta
you've got to say that I mean I just
find I find him I find it strange that
somebody somebody in smart and
perceptive as you Peter would look at
the situation and think the ukrainians
have any desire to wage any form of
Peace settlement which may involve them
seeding territory why should they we
would would we we didn't in
1940s we fought with every every bit of
our strengths to defy the Nazis well I
mean to be on your program all you need
to do is not invite me if you invite me
you should at least do during the
cursive listen you're what I say I'm
never at any stage suggested
you're the one who suggested would
anybody should seat any alarm I would
have thought the position ukrainians
found themselves in now is very strong
if they go into negotiations what do you
think the Russians would simply give
back all the land they've taken I don't
know what would take personal
negotiations as playing come off it
Peter you don't think for a moment
Vladimir Putin would give up that
territory of course he wouldn't you know
that you want me to ask do you want me
to answer your questions or not I want
to I want to I want you to explain why
you think this could possibly get
resolved unless the Ukraine just seeded
their territory Vladimir Putin is not
going to give any of the land back he's
just spent the last year and a half
bombing them into submission to try and
take it why would you give it back how
do you know what is this war about this
war is about Russia under under a
dictator trying to take back territory
that Vladimir Putin believes should
never have been given away in the first
place that's what it's about that's your
version always and again I think that
these I don't think you've made any
secret of it well I'm sorry I it's a
very long and complicated story and one
which you certainly all the people in
broadcast before whom I might attempt to
explain and argue this and not the
person I choose because you'd interrupt
me before I got one tenth of what I was
going to say out and you talk over me
which is what you do the last time we
met each other on television you shut me
down and silence me because I was right
about you stop whining and just answer
the question here you are again do you
want me stop whining and answer the
question or do not because I've got many
other things I'm happy you're filling
all the time that I'm giving you by
whining about not getting airtime say
what you want to say
thank you and and stop talking over me
there's never been any suggestion for me
since this program began that Ukraine
should give up territory that came from
you I said there should be negotiations
negotiations to do what there you go
again the negotiations are it's called
an interview piece I'm allowed to ask
you supplementaries
the viewers the viewers can decide to
themselves whether you're giving me a
fair Shake on them all right look
there's we're going around the houses
here but I appreciate you joining the
program thank you very much let's go to
lordana Lord done it it seems to me
there is a move by people like Peter
Hitchens and others let's just do a
peace deal but I don't know how this can
be based in any reality the ukrainians
don't want to give up any of the
territory that's been taken Putin
clearly isn't going to give it up I
think this is for the birds this idea
they're all going to sit around a table
and just write okay this is peace what
does peace look like in this scenario
well um Pierce conventional wisdom would
say that conflicts like this do end
around negotiation table and trying to
come to some form of agreement but um
where we are at the present moment is
that zielinski's opening position and
Putin's opening position are completely
irreconcilable and therefore for there
to be any negotiation that was fair to
do to Ukraine and to zielinski they have
got to be able to argue from a position
of strength and that comes down to the
battlefield and the success and the
measure of success that the
counter-offensive which will start
relatively soon in the next few weeks
and months has in Ukraine's favor
yeah and I it just seems to me that
Ukraine believe that they can repel the
Russian forces that they can take back
if they have enough Hardware from us and
from other European powers and from
America if we give them the tools I
think they really believe that they can
launch a counter-offensive which will
actually drive Russia out potentially
yes and I think that is entirely
possible
um it'll be a question of seeing how
successful it is
um they've now got from the West what
they're going to have as far as this
counter-offensive is concerned I think
we have to set aside that zielinski's
talk about a jet Coalition that's a
medium to long-term issue but in terms
of the equipment that the West has given
to Ukraine the advice we've given them
the training we've given them they are
now in a good position in the
short term term time frame to launch
this country offensive and I think the
thing to remember is that an offensive
doesn't have to be successful in terms
of destroying the other Army in great
detail but after a miserable winter
poorly LED Russian soldiers poorly
equipped trains and all the rest of it
there is quite a chance that decisive
players by the ukrainians might break
the morale of the average Russian
soldier and break the back of the
Russian army such that the ukrainians
could have some quite significant
success as they did around haki in
September last year yeah now I don't
know what's going to happen but some of
the early reports around buckwood have
indicated that um the the Russian morale
and the Russian soldier is at a pretty
low ebb strike him hard and he might
break and that will then change the
situation for the future negotiations it
might even mean that the Russians decide
to throw in the towel it might even mean
that Putin gets thrown out of power I
think that is I think that's
increasingly likely because we can hope
of that yeah I think it's increasingly
likely that could happen and and Ukraine
they're not asking us all to start
joining in the war they're just asking
us to give them the tools they need and
I think that Rishi neck is absolutely
right to welcome zielinski here and to
say well let's try our language
well our language has to be of that of a
limited War yeah it's got limited
objectives which is simply recapturing
Ukrainian territory with limited means
where everyone's quite well thankfully
holding back from nuclear weapons we're
holding back from giving the ukrainians
very long-range weapons that they could
strike deep into Russia so there are
limits to this and the legitimate
objective is to help the ukrainians
regain their Sovereign territory they've
got every right to do that and we have
every right to help them and that's as
far as it goes and we have to keep
saying it's a limited war and we have to
keep saying NATO is a defensive Alliance
and we have no offensive
um views or attitudes or Ambitions as
far as Russia is concerned I would love
nothing more than for Russia to become a
part of the integrated family of Nations
as back in history it was yeah I
completely agree lordana as always you
make great sense thank you very much
David joining me
thanks peers well assistant next galaxy
is the world's foremost anti-woke
Professor who says dangerous idea
pathogens a killing common sense I
couldn't agree more he joins me live
next
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what about one
two
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
welcome back to Pittsburgh consensus on
any given day there are a lot of news
stories which make me very unhappy not
least to which Arsenal nil Brighton
three well we weren't interested into
private grief but they prove that common
sense is dead
just today we learned that a biological
man entered the 2015 female University
boat race no one was told no one was
allowed to ask
we were told that prison guards have
been banned from calling prisoners
convicts in case it upsets them upsets
convicts
with over 10 percent of teenagers want
to change gender but a third of
teenagers have been taught in schools
that some women have penises what is all
this
why is the world going so completely
nuts well my next guest is an expert on
this phenomenon of the world going nuts
Professor gadsad is the best-selling
author of parasitic mind how infectious
diseases are killing common sense and
also the sad truth about happiness and
he joins me now again thank you for
coming on so just to warm things up I
thought I'd play a little clip of you
talking about me in 2018 let's take a
listen to this
Morgan is a treasonous cretan I don't
care about him as an individual but I
greatly care about his mindset for it is
the singular cause that has led us to
the current conundrum that we face every
day that idiots and enemies of Reason
such as Morgan have a voice in the
public sphere as a day that we inch
closer to violence
well ironically gathered that that
comment actually did move me to nearby
so I'm joking and actually we have found
since then a lot of common ground I know
so I'm not going to labor the point uh
other than you clearly or just as I
don't even remember what that was about
I have no idea what you were talking
about and no one can find out so you
clearly just had a view about me that
you know what it's fine I have views
like that all the time about people but
I'm glad to have you on the show and I
think on a lot of issues we actually
share a lot of a lot of similar thoughts
about this what is going on when we see
things like 10 of teens want to be
transgender in some way when you see
that a a a male biological rower took
part in a very high profile race without
anybody knowing that this was actually a
man sitting in a female boat
um when you see all this
how do we explain it and where does this
where does this end
yeah so it all well first thank you for
having me Pierce uh it all stems from
regrettably I'm saying this as a
professor it all stems from from the
University ecosystem it takes academics
and intellectuals to come up with some
of the
uniquely dumbest ideas and so each of
these idea pathogens that I discussed in
the book post-modernism militant
feminism social constructivism sort of
erase a bit of the edifices of reason
that for most of us can constitutes
common sense so post-modernism for
example argues that there are no
objective truths even thinks that the
average three day old pigeon would
recognize as biological fact is actually
Up For Debate and this is how we end up
erasing all of the common sense that
gives us shared meaning so that men now
who have nine inch penises can be women
they simply have to declare themselves
women and voila they become women yeah I
mean it's completely insane but you're
right facts have been eroded in this
process where people can put their hand
up and talk about my truth as if somehow
their version of the truth which of
course is statistically factual that's
all point of truth that they can have a
version of that which isn't fact based
it's just feeling based
exactly and this is why I I basically
say that all of these idea pathogens
they free us from the pesky shackles of
reality right I don't wish to be
constrained by my genitalia so I just
have to use the magic wand of the trans
prefix and I could be whatever I wish to
be social constructivism is another free
or from from reality it basically says
that anybody could be the next Ronaldo
or Messi if only mommy hugs me enough or
doesn't hug me enough
all have equal potentiality well that's
a very Noble and hopeful message but
it's perfectly rooted in erroneous views
of human nature also the thing about
Ronaldo and Messi I know Cristiano very
well and interviewed him several times
think about those guys they've got a
phenomenal work ethic and you'll never
hear them either of them whining about
being pushed hard or even having coaches
shout at them or whatever it may be it
just seems to me the world is slowly
shrinking into a very weak-minded place
where weakness is celebrated strength is
somehow frowned upon if you try and talk
about mental strength these days people
go mad they're like no how dare you
you're you're belittling people who
aren't mentally strong you're you're
picking on the vulnerable rather than
accentuate the positives
which those two guys represent better
than anybody
and whether it be the soccer players
that you mentioned or the world that I
inhabit in Academia we used to be proud
of the ethos of meritocracy now that's
viewed as a form of white supremacy now
it's my skin color it's my gender
orientation it's my sexual orientation
it's my religion that actually
adjudicates whether I am right or wrong
it's grotesque it's an attack on the
most fundamental deontological
principles that Define the enlightened
societies that we all are proud of and
this is why I am so irreverent and
fighting against all this nonsense and
it's interesting what you said about
meritocracy there there's a move now for
the Oscars and the academy and the way
they go about you know putting
nominations forward so they have to take
a lot of diversity boxes and that all
sounds fine in principle right till you
get to the point where actually it
damages meritocracy
well and not only that pierce I'm sure
you've also heard that someone should
not play example you shouldn't play a
gay part if you yourself are not gay so
what does that mean then Sir Anthony uh
Hopkins should not have played a
sadistic serial killer in size of the
Lambs because clearly he's not really a
serial killer it's insane but not as far
as we know but yeah I mean you're right
I mean who plays Hitler who plays a
Mafia Boss right does everyone in The
Sopranos have to actually be an active
member of the mafia I mean and also it
never works the other way with these
these wokies where you never hear them
say and of course the quid pro quo is
that no gay person can play a straight
part they'll never say that they want
all their virtue signaling cake and eat
it
exactly and you know I to your point
earlier about victimhood I come from
Lebanon I escaped execution in Lebanon
and it's folks like me who come to the
West who are you know completely
befuddled by all of the whining I think
you were mentioning to your previous
guests about him whining I despise
whining what's beautiful about Messi and
Ronaldo is this notwithstanding their
innate Talent they work hard to be the
best that they can be we need to return
to that ethos yes we need to start
celebrating proper Talent proper work
ethic people who really want to put a
shift in them in the work from home
Fiasco and this country is getting
completely out of hand with millions of
people just basically giving up doing
proper work
um you know it's interesting you talk
about professors there because I think
my favorite story of all the canceled
culture stories involved an American
Professor who for 25 years had given a
lecture about offensive language and
eventually a student complained about
his use of offensive language in a
lecture about a offensive language and
he was fired for using offensive
language which she had used to
illustrate the points he was making
about offensive language and at that
point I realized universities are being
run by students and they the students
because of this warped mindset are just
running right on campuses and the
campuses and the people put in charge of
these students are just caving to every
one of their whims and saying okay
whatever you say goes
indeed and look I can tell you I just
past semester I was teaching an MBA
class where I was talking about the
evolutionary roots of anorexia nervosa
and in that lecture I talked about
miscarriages and one student huffed and
puffed that I did not provide trigger
warnings before mentioning something as
you know devastatingly sensitive as
miscarriages and this is someone mean
who went through the Lebanese Civil War
so imagine how much disdain I feel for
such an adult an MBA student that he
requires me to offer trigger warnings
before mentioning a medical reality such
as miscarriages it's unbelievable well I
actually need trigger warnings before I
find myself in close proximity to one of
these woke imbeciles because it actually
does bring me out in Wheels again I
could talk to you online about this I'm
glad we've made up and we're friends
again please come back on on Piers
Morgan and sense it again I really
enjoyed the chat you're the best and my
apologies to Arsenal next year they'll
take it you know what I I'm not so sure
mentally weak they should have signed
Ronaldo when they had the chance back in
October he wanted to come anyway that's
another story great to talk to you thank
you very much well since the next the
Indian Prime Minister plans a campaign
to reclaim looted Treasures held in
British museums and World collections is
it time to hand them back we'll debate
that
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel note
what are you uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk Sue Ella bravam
and talks tough on migration but her
speech is disrupted by protesters Lucas
accused of rigging future elections with
plans to give EU migrants and teenagers
the vote plus prince Andrew refuses to
leave Royal Lodge and fears the royal
family might switch off the electricity
and water to force him out that's all at
nine
[Music]
welcome back joined by talking
contributor Esther cracker and the
associated to the mirror Kevin McGuire
arrest talk first of all about
Eurovision the world's biggest stain on
musical Humanity which turned out to be
to live down to every expectation
absolutely horrific here's a mashup of
the worst moments
[Music]
yeah if I had my old judging hat on
adjust me they're getting buzzed very
quickly like in half a second there was
only one actual talent on display of the
whole thing and it was this woman
[Music]
elegant beautiful talented proper
Princess
um
anyway that's enough said about that
just apart from this when I said the
other day with Louis and Sharon
um when we debated this it is the worst
thing in the world this show I said
nobody actually likes it it's a complete
myth and then you go to the poll uh do
you how much do you care about yourself
a great deal six percent a fair amount
13 not very much 32 not at all 45
otherwise 77 of the population don't
care I rest my case
um it's not wasting any more time
talking about it uh
let's talk about uh uh India getting
back looted to treasures and obviously
Greece and other countries as well we've
been moving to get back very
an extravagant Treasures which were
looted from them by the ghastly Brits
should this takes me back to the ongoing
debate about reparations about obviously
about basically paying for historical
sin should we be giving stuff back well
of course not I mean the only reason why
they feel emboldened to do this is
because one no one is asking them about
their historical sort of uh should I say
atrocities but also because the UK is in
the groups of an identity crisis if we
could actually have a mature
conversation about the Empire and what
it means to be British and how we
shouldn't pay for the sins of the past
Narendra Modi who is a Hindu nationalist
who has a lot to answer for himself
would never feel emboldened to say give
us back our old Treasures how far back
do you go is he going to talk about you
know the Mughal Empire and all the
atrocities they committed is he going to
talk about you know the Gujarati riots
in 2001 and all the predominantly Muslim
victims that were in his State when this
happened you know he's choosing to this
is my problem with all of it it's it's
like it's like the slavery reparation
debate are you going to demand that
black people around the world who had
slaves are they going to have to pay
reparations too in other words how far
do you take it yeah I think it's
different at the reparations debate same
principle though it's it's like paying
for historical sins isn't it look unless
you've got a receipt for the diamond or
apartment marbles you you've nicked them
basically you've take you've taken them
by phone
it's not just Britain it it is other
countries that had Empires or invaded
occupied and looted they're all going to
have to face this up now why why though
Kevin want to let it go well because the
countries would like their Treasures
back that way I'm sure they would and we
would like stuff the Romans the Vikings
I can't see what's wrong with it though
as long as they're going back to
democracy here's my question for you
when does Britain get a slice of this
pie oh we got it now look look we we
build this we built it we built the
country on an Empire which was there for
our benefit not the countries we
occupied and looted and then Industrial
Revolution I'm sorry many of those
countries wouldn't exist in their modern
form if it wasn't for that history is
history you cannot change it it is but
the argument and the demonizing of the
Empire is fine but you have to balance
it with some of the good things that the
Empire achieved it wasn't all
most of the best schools in India and
now are schools that were based on the
colonial Empire and British British
education system do they give that back
yeah but look we took immense Welsh uh
wealth out of it look at Charlie now we
were burning down
India is now an immensely wealthy
country exactly so it's one of the
biggest economies in the world overall
with a with a hundreds of millions of
very poor people let me that's true but
let me ask you this question which is
separate to what we've just been talking
about a theater company wants to cast
girls to play Charlie in Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory fantastic I'd go see
that leave it alone see it as always
experiment why do we have to ruin
everything if you if you want Charlie to
be Charlie Bucket
the way he was written in he was written
change
to talk about it it's not because
they were stunned to see Charlie's now a
girl Charlie's not a girl Charlie was
written as a boy he is a boy is that
calling James Bond a girl no he's a
bloke that's it Shakespeare's Hamlet is
always set in different places
that's it for me whatever up to Keep It
Uncensored and remember boys and boys
girls and girls it's not that difficult
this it's easy
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
thank you
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it